(gentle playful music)
- [Narrator] This is the
mossy frog, a tiny amphibian,
found predominantly
within the flooded caves
of northern Vietnam's forests.
Its main mode of defense,
you're looking at it.
The mossy frog's skin is
a blotchy green and brown,
a perfect color match
for the mossy environment
it's found in.
If threatened, it will
curl up and play dead
to hide from possible predators.
They are semi-aquatic,
and the suction-like discs
at the end of its toes
make it an agile climber
when out of the water.
For food, they are opportunistic,
meaning they'll feed on
anything available to them,
as their habitat goes
through constant change.
One change in particular
is the recent deforestation
of northern Vietnam's forests.
As the forests have become smaller,
so has the mossy frog's population,
landing them on the
endangered species list.
This is the mossy frog.
(ding)